hello resilient wonder women I'm gal
gadot I play Wonder Woman in the
first-ever
live action Wonder Woman movie and I'm
Chris Pine I play Captain Steve Trevor
the first man that Wonder Woman has ever
laid eyes as an Amazon Princess Diana
was trained to be an unconquered Vil
warrior on the island paradise of the
mascara but when an American pilot yours
truly crashes on their shores and tells
of a massive conflict raging in the
outside world they go on an adventure
together where Diana discovers his
powers and true destiny I want the book
the story full of action and intrigue
misty just what it takes to become one
of the greatest superheroes don't make
Wonder Woman when it opens in Brazil on
June 1st
[Music]
I used to want to save the world this
beautifully
but the closer you get
and more you see the great darkness
within
I learned this the hard way
a long long time ago
what is your mission just off the war
front for the war to end all wars
rippen far deadlier than you can ever
imagine
and welcome to our
where we are you are in more danger than
you cannot stand by while innocent lives
are lost
be careful guys
who is this woman she's my secretary sir
she's a very good secretary
because our sacred duty to defend the
world and it's what I'm going to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how can a woman pass the decisiveness
right we use our principles although I
am NOT opposed to engaging in a bit of
fisticuffs should the occasion arise
you